thank you very much uh i would like to
thank the organizers for inviting me and
for the opportunity to hear so many
interesting talks i've got plenty of
open problems uh now in my head so this
talk changed throughout the the week
as i wanted to show some dependencies of
previous talks and remove the
uh the intersection however i was not
able to do it with the talk that just
took place an hour ago so i'm very sorry
for the repetitions that will be present
i will be giving a very easy talk on a
very classical problem platism uh this
is a part of a joint work with uh thomas
scala from magdeburg currently at mark
the book
uh please uh if you have any questions
feel free to ask so to show you how easy
my talk is i will start by reminding
that
uh irreducible representations
correspond to young diagrams and i will
even say more how how one can think
about it namely i would like to think
about it about uh in in terms of sure
functors so to a young diagram i
associate a sure functor how does it
work
i take
i take the space v
if i consider the group slv i tensor it
as many times as my young diagram has uh
has as many boxes as my young diagram
has and then
i act on the tensor
power with the young symmetrizer so most
of you know young symmetrizers
here you can consider them just as a map
that takes a tensor permutes it
and associates certain coefficient and
sums up so for example for the symmetric
power you just take all possible
permutations with coefficient one and
for the wedge power you just take also
all possible permutations but the
coefficient is equal to the sign of
permutation so as
as we know like this we can get all
irreducible representations of slv
varying just the
young diagram but as we defined it
it really didn't matter that the
starting representation was the most
trivial one v i could have done it for
any representation take the tensor power
act with young symmetrizer so in fact s
lambda is a functor from representations
to representations if i apply it to the
trivial to to just to v
then then i get the irreducible
representations but when i start
applying it to other
more complicated representations i in
general i get reducible representations
and this is what i call the platysm so
application of a
sure
functor to
to another uh
sure functor so here i stopped omitting
the
the vector space v as i usually will not
be interested in it as long as v is
sufficiently many dimensional the
decomposition of such a composition
in terms of young diagrams is just the
same so the most well-known sure
functors are for sure the symmetric and
the wedge power
and and and also in this talk these are
the two
uh sure functors we'll be mostly uh
interested in so here is an example we
take s4 of s3 in c3 and when we
decompose it
uh such thing with multiplicity one
appears so here i mean a young diagram
with three rows and four boxes in each
row so the first question is what is it
and when did it appear on this
conference
the discrimination
this is the this is the you know what is
diagonal
yes i mean on monday we saw the degree
for uh invariant for plane cubics
uh great
so so so bernstein first gave a very
nice talk about invariants and we see
that if we know platism in particular
invariants appear there and we can
recognize them
as rectangular shapes
great
so
i hope this is like one of the
motivations
to understand platisms so if we just
focus on symmetric powers of symmetric
powers it means that we are trying to
understand
uh polynomials uh in coefficients of of
polynomials
uh so unfortunately i'm sure that almost
every expert in a representation theory
has got his own favorite way to compute
platisms
but
there is no really good combinatorial
formula
and also many many speakers refer to it
there are many
formulas how to compute it but uh i
guess that we are still looking for a
really good really first fast one even
for even for symmetric powers
so the aim the general aim would be to
fully understand polynomials in
coefficients of polynomials so here this
will be like degree d polynomials in
coefficients of degree k polynomials but
we already know this is difficult this
is very very difficult so the aim of the
talk will be a little bit different
a little bit more modest so understand
low degree polynomials in coefficients
of arbitrary polynomials
so i would like to make it very clear i
will be considering small d and
arbitrary k
yes and any questions at this point
this is my aim i don't care about
complexity about other things i really
want to understand
low degree polynomials in terms
for arbitrary inner polynomials
and you you might be disappointed not
much it's known about this even for for
small d's
but not much doesn't mean nothing
so what is what is known uh so one of
the first results is due to thrall in
1942
he he provided a formula for the second
symmetric power of of of n
symmetric power and it turns out that
the multiplicity is always one or zero
and it's precisely one
when your lambda has just two rows and
both of them are even
so for me i would interpret this results
that trial understood quadrics
for for in coefficients of arbitrary
polynomials and you already can see
that an important thing that was often
referred to
during this conference that the lattice
structure
plays a role so it's not only
inequalities or polynomials but the rest
module or some number
gives you the result whether the
multiplicity is zero or not here it's
very easy just modulo two
uh but but
later we'll see that that such things
are are quite important okay so we we
understand quadrix and of course when we
understand quadrix what's the next
natural question that people try to
answer
cubics and cubics we also understand so
there are precise explicit formulas to
decompose s3 of sk
this is not very very
difficult there are
there are
many people who obtained so
this already is is later than 1942 there
are many different formulas but
in particular there are explicit
formulas i should say that
also formulas for s mu s k where mu is
arbitrary partition of free
r
are known
great
so so what about
quartix
uh there is a paper of how
where he says
how he can obtain formulas for qualities
and he also say that interested people
where can contact him
but
he will not put money that the formulas
are correct he just claims that his
methods are correct to obtain the
formulas
that's something that's something at
least we've got good methods to to
yes i did
yes i did and he replied
um
great
so
so so let's say that quartics
can be understood
um
so what is the problem you may you may
ask i mean why
how can someone have methods but he's
not
like claiming that that that the result
he has is 100 correct
uh the thing is that these formulas are
more and more complicated
and this i should say as for sk i mean
these are still quite old results
but many different approaches to smu sk
when mu is a partition of free there are
there are papers uh after 2000 about
that
um great so the formulas of course
become become more and more complicated
but there are no negative signs there
right
okay this is not a summation formula
it's an explicit formula so it's a
function in k and lambda and explicit
function so let's say you take the
length of the second row you add to it k
you divide by two you take the floor and
this is the multiplicity what do you
subtract is the question
well a polynomial has subtractions but
it's a formula it's a formula it's a
really question why do you need to
subtract
when you write down that thing like you
wrote down is three something something
like that
is it like that
so here the coefficient is like 0 1. so
this one i would interpret as a function
that
that takes lambda 1 and returns 0 if
lambda 1 is odd
and 1 if lambda 1 is even
i think this formula i interpret it as
such a function
and the formulas for s3 and s4 they are
of such a type they take of course more
lambdas
they take they take uh
yeah
they take they take let's say let's say
k
and then it's like
if lambda 1 is greater than lambda 2
plus lambda 3 and here an explicit
coefficient that can have minuses like
lambda 1 minus lambda 2 plus floor of k
divided by 2. i mean this is not the
result but i'm i'm just saying what type
of formula one obtains
to that formula can it become negative
no i mean it it's a formula for the
multiplicity so when you evaluate it on
reasonable lambda and k are there
monomials in the formula that have a
negative yes
yes
yes
but we are not computing combinatorial
objects of certain type and subtracting
them so this is not like like like like
the usual problem that happens that you
compute certain types of combinatorial
objects and you start subtracting them
it's an explicit formula you are not
computing any objects
um okay so what what would be the the
approach the approach is as usual and
that's presented on a previous talk
through characters so
you probably didn't forget in one hour
that characters are symmetric
polynomials associated to
representations and that the trace of a
representation is a symmetric polynomial
in eigenvalues
and
for irreducible representations we've
got super important functions
that that are called sure polynomials
and form a basis of the space of
symmetric polynomials
uh i even prepared an example but i
guess it's it's very clear by now that
if you take just a two-dimensional
vector space
and if you act with with with with uh
sl2 the the character is like this a
complete symmetric polynomial yes this
this one comes from the action on e1
times e1
this one comes from the action on e1
times e2 this one comes from an action
on e2 times e2
yes so this is a complete symmetric
polynomial you can easily see that that
for symmetric powers you will always get
a complete symmetric polynomials of of
this degree
and i will denote it by h so h for me
will be a complete symmetric polynomial
uh why are we interested in characters
because decomposing a representation
into irreducible components is just the
same as writing the character
in terms of
offshore
polynomials with coefficients because
they form a basis
everything is clear so what is our aim
now our aim now is of course to
understand the character of platysm
and later to decompose it in terms of
sure functors
so first we have to go from the platysm
that was defined as composition of
uh offshore polynomials to the level of
of of symmetric polynomials so here the
circle will be the platinum and it turns
out that of course you can do it on the
level of symmetric polynomials
so if you if your g and f represent
sure
uh polynomials then this circle
uh will represent their platysm the
character of the platysm
and this platysm has very easy and nice
properties namely in the outer
thing it's an endomorphism of rings of
symmetric polynomials
and
if the outer thing is just a power sum
so if i
and it's a definition
phi n
of x i just mean
sum of x i to nth power it will be a
very important function for me
so if you do not like to compose
sure factors you can consider this
as a definition of platism on level of
symmetric functions because any
symmetric function can be expressed in
those phi's
as a ring generated by by those sorry by
those c psi psi
and then when you express your outer
think
in terms of psi
using the fact that is an endomorphism
of ring of symmetric polynomials and
applying this formula
you can compute arbitrary platinums
so some people are nodding but i'm not
sure if it's yeah
most people are
yes but they do
they do
so this isn't the case
this is supposed to just plug in all the
terms
yes yes here you see yes
yes but but but but i mean i i prefer to
do it this way because for for for
further application so right now we will
just use this proposition if you would
like to know more i mean this is like in
mcdonald's book uh very classical uh so
let's do it for platism so i repeat the
strategy express the outer thing in size
and then use the fact that this is
endomorphism of ring of symmetric
polynomials
so this is the formula for the character
of of platism of n s mu and sk
there are some strange numbers here and
let me let me explain what are what are
these numbers
using the proof of this thing at the
same time so a few numbers are expressed
here so the sum is over all alphas that
divide d
and d alpha is the number of partitions
of cycle type alpha so if you have a
partition uh of permutation yes sorry of
permutation uh permutations of cycle
type alphas so if you have got any
permutation you can decompose it to
cycles and you can ask how many
permutations are with the same
decomposition to two cycles so this is
the alpha and the proof is very easy you
can see that this is like a two line
proof uh the
the thing is to decompose
uh the character
uh the the sure polynomial
in terms of power silence so here row is
a partition
row is a partition
so row equals row one up to some row s
and i define it just to be a product
of raw ice
and rho with a number is defined above
so it's just a product
of
power sums and that's some
uh sorry sorry sorry sorry
uh in the sum
up about straight to the left
that
yes yes yes yes yes there uh there is no
alpha here i'm very sorry for that
and this phi is subside psi of row is
defined as the product of the psi
this is a polynomial defined there
this is
this is just a number this is just a
number and i i'm now going to explain
this because i didn't say what is this
yes i didn't say
so
recall
that partitions label not only
representations of the symmetric linear
group they also
correspond to representations of the
complete symmetric group
and
complete symmetric group also have
characters
and by
say mu i mean the character of the
representation associated to mu
of an sd representation
and now i can evaluate it on a partition
that represents a permutation because a
partition represents a permutation up to
conjugation because it defines the cycle
type
also some people are noting but i think
that not not all people maybe there are
some questions
so just to sum up this is the formula to
express the sure polynomials in terms of
of
products of power sums with coefficients
that are just numbers that we can
understand and compute
dot and now using the fact that the
platysm is just
an endomorphism of rings
in the outer thing we can put it
and compose it with the character of the
symmetric power which is just the
complete
uh symmetric polynomial as we have seen
and we obtain this easy formula
d alpha is a number of uh of
permutations of a given cycle type you
can write a precise formula but i think
it's easier to to just remember that
it's a number of certain permutations
uh basically should while duality right
yes you can derive it from survive
duality
yes you can do that
although i always did it on polynomials
um great
so
at this point when i think i learned it
from laurel i thought the game is over
for platism we know we know the
character
so we know
the
polynomial what's the problem
i mean we just reduced
a very complicated problem to a problem
in linear algebra we have to
understand this polynomial as a linear
combination of sure polynomials
and
the problem is i think more or less the
same as in professor popov's lecture
linear algebra when you are doing it in
coefficients of polynomials
becomes hard becomes hard because there
are so many of things
so
so so so this is the reason why this
problem is not completely solved i mean
you can try to do it like
combinatorically or using linear algebra
but the formulas become complicated the
the the computations become more and
more complicated
but we still have our aim we really want
to understand low degree polynomials in
arbitrary polynomials so we don't care
if it becomes complicated we have to do
it
so what can we do
so i think there are two things in
general that one can do in such a case
either
really aim
to
really obtain the aim using some new
methods that people before us didn't use
or try to ask a different question maybe
not an explicit answer
but
something something
connected to the answer
and i will present both of these
approaches point one and point two
so point one
we have to use some some new methods
that that that people before us didn't
have
so
guess what will be the methods that
people in the 80s didn't have
well
the the first problem is to understand
is to understand
this polynomial
psi rho
hk
i don't know if you see what it is this
is just a product
of
complete
symmetric polynomials
so first of all this is a product of psi
rho i h k because i told you that the
platysm is in is is an endomorphism in
the outer function so we would like to
understand this
but this is just
h k
of
x to rho i
a complete symmetric polynomial of
degree k
in
coefficients that are not variables but
powers of variables
so what are the coefficients of of these
coefficients and we have a product of
such things
how can we understand the coefficient
well let us translate it to a purely
combinatorial problem as
as a few speakers before me did
so you can immediately see that the
coefficients
of this polynomial
are governed
by
the following combinatorial object
you take a matrix
your matrix has got certain weights
and
so the entries will be x i j
and you want
the row sums
to be equal
to k
to a given fixed number
and you want so excited numbers
yes numbers we will be counting number
of matrices with non-negative integral
entries with rows
summing up to a given number and
weighted
column sums
weighted column sums
so
this sort of tells me which monomials
i choose
in each of the product very very easy
translation
so this expression
first one is the
columns in the fixed rows that come over
j and the next one is some override
uh
well that depends how you how you number
them i here i gave i and here i gave j
sorry
probably many mathematics so this is the
arithmetic of the degree
yes yes yes yes yes
i just encode the coefficients very
simple
but the good thing is
that
that now we can apply new methods that
people didn't have in the 80s namely
this is a perfect job for a computer
because this is a polytope this is a
polytope and there are new algorithms
people developed new algorithms to
compute such things in particular
there's a bar vinok program which
greatly deal
solves the problem of computing
parametrically
uh of computing parametrically
uh the
the number of
points in in a cone so i had a few
questions about the binoc program
because it was it was mentioned during a
few talks
uh we we use it through isl library it's
still under contract construction but it
works already
very very well
so what does bharavi knock
we have a polyhedral cone
we have a poly so this is a
three-dimensional polyhedral cone
uh
and this is and and we have a projection
so i will be projecting it to a
two-dimensional space
uh and this is the input
and the output is a counting function of
fibers so i would like to know
what
what is the cardinality of a fiber above
a given point
but i don't want the number i want it as
a function
so what do i get
notice that this ray
projects here
and of course i get a different function
on this
piece and a different function on this
piece because
because the the facets supporting the
cones are different
yes so i get a quasi-polynomial here
and a
quasi-polynomial here what i mean by a
quasi-polynomial i mean just a
polynomial but the coefficients depend
on parameters modulo a fixed number
and this is the output of a bar we knock
he gives you the chamber decomposition
and he gives you
the quasi-polynomial in each
chamber
just to check if the audience is with me
what would i get if i would project it
to a line
so this polytope projects to a point
and i'm counting the cardinality of a
fiber
yes someone is with me
great
okay so i i project it to the line
and i assume that there is a poly top at
height one
and then there is a dilation of this
polytube at height two
so in fact the projection function comes
the number of integral points inside the
dilations of the polytope and this is
i mean depending if this is rational or
integral it's either a polytube or quasi
polytope uh the earhart hilbert
yes whether it's a polynomial or
quasi-polynomial depends if this is
integral or
rational
great so we obtain we obtain a lot of
cones
we we have to project them so
i cheated here a little bit because i
told you how to understand the
coefficients of
of the
um of the
of the character of the platysm but
coefficients are not enough
to to to understand it as a
decomposition of sure factors but there
is a standard trick that was mentioned
during
the previous talk and many other talks
you can you can you can call it uh in
many different ways a finite difference
operator it amounts to multiplying your
polynomial by the discriminant and then
looking for the particular coefficient
there also a job that the computer does
very very well for you
and we get explicit answers where mu is
a per any partition of four or five
so in particular we also obtain explicit
answer for s mu of wedge k
of course don't try to implement it as i
did it in the talk because the computer
will break but after a few tricks you
can you can do it with with with without
problems
no for any k
a formula for any k
so i should mention there are 1 000
programs and the best one is lee to
compute platism for fixed mu and fixed
inner thing but we don't want that we
treat k as a parameter in in everything
we do
it's a parameter
and our formulas are completely explicit
so it gives we obtain a decomposition of
the space of case and lamp that's the
domain
and finite decomposition into chambers
and it's each chamber you get a
quasi-polynomial explicitly given by the
computer
uh yeah so this is what
this is what i just said
yes so we have we have a space
in
the domain is k lambda
you don't need
both but let's say we have both and then
you have a chamber decomposition
and in each chamber you get a explicit
quasipolynomial
that gives you the answer to your
problem so if you would like to then
know yeah i i will i will pass later
what you what you can explicitly do with
with that
not not really that huge um
we've got numerix it's like well yes new
grows of course
the most
foreign yes yes that that what keeps it
still reasonable
i i guess like 100
i i don't remember
sorry
i don't know 100 yeah not not i mean
it's it's it's it's that many that you
can look at it being
as a human being although you are not
supposed to do that
decomposition of 75 75
yes because
they are writing it explicitly not as a
formula but we've got s5 of sk for nk
nk
as a function in k
for example for me partition 4 how many
chamber do you get
i have to check in my uh we have
five 100
i guess something between
you use projection once or many times
sorry oh
many times um
number of new boxes factorial
um and and i didn't show you any chamber
decomposition because for quadric there
was no chamber the composition but
already for cubics you need this chamber
decomposition so there is a different
formula depending on inequalities and of
course there is a different formula this
is a quasi polynomial depending on the
rest modular fixed number
so if one doesn't care how you got the
formula there is a precise formula
for the composition up till s5 yes is
that what you're saying yes
yes even s mu where mu is any partition
of 5.
s5 of sk
it's it's there's a formula in k so not
even for fixed k parametric in k
so we understand quintix of any
polynomials
no
do you still have to do something to
find out yes so this is this trick that
was mentioned by it was called sure
something i mean you multiply by the
discriminant
and and you look but we do this we do
this of course we are not computing
weights we are really computing
multiplicities we are not cheating
yes that i didn't talk about
yes we did that
yes all right
um okay so
so so but this is only half of what we
did i told you that there is a second
point you can try to
understand things not explicitly but for
example the asymptotics so i already
told you that that this thing is a
piecewise quasi polynomial for fixed mu
in k and lambdas so for me there is a
very natural question what's the leading
term of this quasi-polynomial can we
understand it and when you are doing
combinatorics you immediately see that
there is the candidate for the leading
term and and and you are sure that this
is your leading term and then you start
looking at the literature and you find
that
people before you also identified this
leading term and they also were sure
that this is the leading term but it
seems no one really proved it so uh how
conjectured it in the 80s
uh i contacted like 15 experts i guess
and and
r is little with richardson that's a big
name it's really coming from pierre's
rule here uh
yeah so so more or less if you want to
understand lambda in s mu
s n
uh
you should understand lambda inside sn
tensor the weight of mu
this is much easier because this is just
it's the number of killings of a
cavalier with with a with yes yes yes
but but in this case it's like even
easier because it comes from pieris
because it's a symmetric power
yes
yes yes i call it the pierce rule yes
but it is yes yes yes yes this number
but but
but anyway yes we we know how to compute
this
yes
well at least the leading term it's
connected to the volume of of of the
polytope
and then
if you want to understand the
multiplicity here just multiply by this
number
dimension of mu is the dimension of mu
as a representation of the symmetric
group
um
okay
this this should be i guess many experts
probably probably should feel that this
is obvious i
is from littlewood richardson by which i
mean i mean i mean the term
the term in the tensor product so what's
the multiplicity in the tensor product
of what which lambda
lr of lambda in there yeah yeah correct
what was d now
uh d is is is mu
oh
mu yes
so for example for symmetric power i
mean imagine that this is just the
symmetric power so that this is just d
well
what's the difference between a tensor
product and the symmetric power if you
take an arbitrary tensor if you
symmetrize it more or less
one over d factorial things will fall
here
and and and and if your partition is is
just one row then this is just the
trivial representation that has
dimension one so you see that this is
very intuitive
uh so so so so we also prove it
uh and i will be very happy to discuss
uh with experts uh because maybe i still
believe that there should be a very easy
not combinatorial but a representation
theoretic uh proof of that
um so conclusions and future plans there
was a toggle by matthias so what's the
difference with the talk by matias he
was changing the degree keeping the
inner functor fixed
uh so so he had like one variety and
changed the degree of polynomials i'm
doing the other thing around so i'm
changing the variety and changing the
polynomials but i'm keeping the the
degree
so
after talking to lauren and other people
it seems that this question mark should
be a
dot
so from combinatorial formulas it's very
clear that this should be a
quasi-polynomial for large k but it
seems that it's a quasi-polynomial just
from the start so it means that you can
understand the platysm just by
understanding it asymptotically for very
large values of k because the quasi
polynomial is determined by by by by
finitely many values so if you are able
to understand it for large k you can
deduce the quasi polynomial and
understand it for for small k so i i
hope this will be a work in progress
with lauren
um
oh no there's a question mark i see i
think so well
lauro and matthias made that theorem
already i think
so if you if you are interested in the
explicit decompositions of s5 or s4 of
sn this is the web page we set out for
it
if you really want to see the formulas
i should say that this formula you can
know you can do much more than just
asking for a multiplicity for given k
and lambda you can evaluate it
symbolically so for example you can test
your conjecture what's the multiplicity
when the row of the second uh
when the second row in your diagram
equals the third one so you just input
lambda 2 equal to lambda 3 in our
formulas and the computer does it for
you if you are lucky the fortune formula
simplifies a lot and confirms or
contradicts your
conjecture
and then how fast is the evaluation of
an explicit formula so here is an
example
if you would like to know what the
multiplicity of such a random young
diagram inside such a platinum it's this
and you are not supposed to see it
but the evaluation of such a formula it
takes under one second
and thomas said that we can do it when
when these numbers would have million of
digits
so so explicit formula is like really
fast
there is no mathematics there it's just
it's just
it's just showing that we can do it for
really arbitrary numbers evaluate the
formula
and even beyond
so we've got formulas up to s5 if you
would be interested in s6 we can
probably push it
well there are a few tricks we reduce a
number of variables we use the bar v
knock
we
even such things as an ordering of
summation played a big role in the
computation so we have sums and of
course there are commutative but but
choosing the right order in the
summation somehow the result depends on
that
i cannot compute there is a big xcm
between the parts of the
the numbers were random one two three
four five six seven eight one two three
four five six seven eight one two three
four five six seven
it's random in binary representation
and the first one what's that the first
one is so so that it makes sense i mean
the total weight has to be equal to five
times one two three four five six seven
eight nine one two three four five six
seven eight nine
because otherwise it's zero
that wouldn't be interesting
yes that one
uh so i plan also to tell you what are
the weak points of our algorithm but i
guess i don't have time
i have time i i can tell you
so there are a few
very weak points of our algorithm so
this computer expert so first of all why
does isl library work so well because
when you have loops in your program for
loops this is like a parameterization of
some geometric object
in in a high dimensional space and they
want to optimize for loops very well so
they want to have a better
parameterization of this object so they
really work hard to make this algorithms
nice but the things with algorithms and
parameterizations inside them is that
these formulas were never meant to be
seen by human beings
but
they've got the thing that transforms
the computer formula into a human
readable output and read it back in
but it's very very bad they are working
now on it and they are not very much
interested so our formulas are in human
readable output but when you feed the
computer
our formula into the computer because
this reading function is so bad this
takes time just to read the formula
i mean it's not a huge formula it's a
few pages so you can look at it being a
human being and once it's read in your
memory computer can edit subtract it do
anything with it like in fractions of a
second but they just didn't pay
attention into the reading thing so if
you just want to do one evaluation it
may take long because reading in our
formula takes long and another thing is
we already know that our formula is f
formula it's not the formula and
the problem is that a function for
example constantly equal to 2
you can you can you can present it
as a function that is 2 for x greater or
equal to 0
and
x plus 1 square minus x square minus 2x
plus 1 for x less than 0. i mean you can
do it
and the problem is that the computer can
sort can cannot always join and say oh
this is the same as this
so the computer doesn't care because
evaluating this one and evaluating this
one is very easy for him but a human
being would care to have like sort of a
minimal representation and i hope to
uh
i hope to be able to
present it uh
maybe in in a year how what is for
example the minimal chamber the
composition for arbitrary platinums
yeah so you take for example if you have
these two chambers at least two formulas
[ __ ] random numbers objectives those
are the same this particular notice how
these two chambers just see for random
numbers are those the same yeah he
usually has method
yes yes yes so so for sure there would
be like a good post processing thing but
the thing is that probably it will still
not feel or fit on one page maybe you
will be able to reduce it to two pages
so probably jm also wouldn't be happy to
look at it and for computer it sort of
doesn't matter anyway he evaluates it in
one tenth of a second
but certainly certainly we could do
better
thank you